well to West Africa now where Ghana is
stepping up Security in its border
region amid growing concerns of jihadist
violence that's due partly to an
Insurgency led by groups linked to
Al-Qaeda and the so-called Islamic State
that Insurgency has spread from Mali to
neighboring Burkina fazo the crisis has
displaced more than 2 million people
there with many of them now fleeing
South into Ghana as attacks continue
DW's Maxwell souk visited a cab hosting
refugees close to the Border
arrived in this camp in Ghana early
August the porridge is cooking will be
her only meal today but at least she
feels safe here
she escaped with her children in Burkina
Faso where she had these attacks I
intensifying
tafia says her life is on the threat
back home
the terrorists came to attack our
community in Burkina Faso they killed
our husbands and burnt our houses so we
ran through the bushes to the
neighboring towns where we got buses to
Ghana
at the border with the Burkina Faso
makeshift comes like this one are
becoming common
authorities estimate that around 2 000
people moved here in the past year with
new arrivals almost weekly
today the refugees are waiting for water
to be delivered
it is hard for officials to provide all
the necessary Aid as the numbers keep
Rising the way they run and came even
the clothes what they had on them was
the only thing that they had even
towards them very difficult the children
even sleep is very difficult so there
was the need for us to intervene and
that is why we We Came as the head of
the district ahmetahiro Works
relentlessly to find basic support
UNICEF and the Red Cross are providing
tense and medication
tahiru also tries to count the local
community as some are uncomfortable with
their refugees settling here everybody
in this community is worried because we
don't know exactly where they are and
where they come from who knows where the
terrorists will come from
Ghana has increased its security
presence in this region as jihadists
continue to expand their activities
porous Brothers reminisce subject of
concern not only for residents
the biggest threat rather is combatants
pretending to be civilians fleeing the
clashes coming into Ghana and preparing
the grounds
back at the camp those who fled also
feared the conflict could spill over the
Border
feed her children Sofia goes day by day
looking for work from surrounding Farms
with the hope that Ghana will remain a
peaceful Refuge
there is not enough food for us or
enough clean water and shelter these are
all problems to us we need support
while it is generally safe for the
refugees and discounts safia is looking
forward to returning to Burkina Faso
with your children to live in peace